Speaker 1: Let's go next to let's
go to Ricardo from Oklahoma.
Speaker 2: Yes, hi, can
Speaker 1: you hear me? I can hear you.
Speaker 2: Excellent, excellent. What a
pleasure. What an honor, actually pleasure.
My question to you is we talk a lot about fake
news. I want to talk about social engineering.
Do you think fake news is social engineering
Speaker 1: in in what sense? What in
what way would it be social engineering?
Speaker 2: So fake news sounds very easy,
very, very simple. You know, somebody
just post something fake online as fake
news. Social engineering has a more a deeper
purpose, you know, has a strategy behind it.
Like right now on YouTube, you can see commercials
of Donald Trump saying that he's asking a lot of
people to vaccinate and all that, but he's also
actually asking for money somewhere else. So to
me, that's kind of like social engineering, trying
to have people believe he is a good person asking
for people to vaccinate yet. To me, that's that's
a way to ask for money and convince people to
to get money. And you see what I'm saying?
Speaker 1: So the the definition of social
engineering is some kind of central plan to
manage social change and regulate the behavior
of a society. So the way that fake news could be
social engineering would be if one view of fake
news would be fake. News spreads really easily.
And so it's profitable. And so individually,
all of these purveyors of fake news put out
fake news not to influence society, but just
to make money like that would be fake news. Not
being social engineering, you could say fake
news. So it was social engineering. If there was
a concerted effort in order to influence people to
behave a certain way on the basis of fake news
that is being spread. So like you could say,
maybe there is a social engineering motivation
for fake news spread about the vaccine,
and that would be to further some political goal
or to cause chaos at school board meetings or
whatever the case may be. So. Sure. I mean, in
that sense, the coordinated spread of fake news
could be a form of social engineering. I don't
know that we know that to be the case necessarily.
Speaker 2: OK. I appreciate your time
and your show. It's a great show,
great source of information and knowledge,
and I appreciate you taking my call.
Speaker 1: Thanks, Ricardo. I appreciate you
calling in. Interesting. Interesting for for sure.